hey guys it's Justine and today we're
checking out the brand new airpods 2.
now these do look very very similar to
the original airpods pro version but
these have some new little surprises so
let's open it up and check it out
[Music]
ah look at this
so on the bottom we now have a speaker
and over here we have a little lanyard
Loop now this speaker is going to be
incredible for find my so if you happen
to lose these you can play a sound and
you'll be able to find them so much
easier because of how loud the sound is
they also have it now so when you're
doing the find my this light will light
up so if you happen to lose these
somewhere where it's dark that'll help
you be able to find them hopefully you
lose them face up because if you lose
them face down you're not going to be
able to see the light but I like that
they added that so it'll start blinking
and it'll help you find them another
thing that is very exciting for me
because as you guys know all of my
airpods reviews I've always been able to
kind of keep them in my ear but they
don't stay in for long durations so me
personally has still been using the
first gen airpods with the long ear
stems and it's sad because the sound
quality on these newer versions is so
incredible that I'm missing out on a
whole new world so my dear friends at
Apple let's see what they have for all
of us now who may have had problematic
ears and a lot of these airpods may not
have stayed in they now have look at
this an extra set of ear tips for you to
try out now I tried out the extra small
version when I was at Apple and I'm so
excited to announce that they actually
stayed in my ear now I didn't do a run
test I didn't get to actually really
thoroughly test it out for the most part
they stayed in and I could not be more
happy like this is
this is game changing another fun little
addition is you can actually get your
memoji customized and engraved in your
airpods now that's so cool so let's put
on the extra small bye bye medium
I can't believe this
[Music]
it stays in this is so exciting I can't
believe it oh my gosh the noise
cancellation is on this is so great the
thing that is most impressive is a lot
of headphones that have the transparency
mode is it sounds like you're listening
to everything in a can it sounds like
it's very tinny and with these it's a
very natural listen like everything
sounds normal like I don't sound weird I
don't sound like I'm underwater so when
you're turning the volume up and down on
the stem you're just running your finger
up and down and it gives you like this
little pop sound so it's like
it's a really bad rendition but it gives
you that feedback so you know that
you're turning the volume up one little
level each at a time okay let's get
these all connected because I want to
try them out I'm just so excited that
these are actually staying in my ear no
it's happening it's happening it's
happening
so the cool thing with the Apple watch
is it does have a noise decibel reader
and it'll link up to your airpods and
it'll be able to adjust and show you the
decibel reading what the outside sound
is like when you actually have the air
pods in so it's actually able to safely
reduce the noise around you and bring it
down to a safer level so that your
hearing isn't damaged so compared to the
previous version it does have two times
more noise cancellation power which is
pretty impressive considering the first
version was actually pretty good so with
that brand new H2 chip you're getting
high band connectivity new low
Distortion driver with custom amplifier
a longer battery life you'll be able to
get six hours of listening time on a
single charge which is 30 more than the
previous version in total you get about
30 hours of listening with the case
another new feature is personalized
spatial audio now spatial audio is
pretty impressive and if you've ever
tried it out it's pretty great to listen
to music and watch TV but this will now
be personalized so what does that mean
okay check this out you're actually able
to scan your ear and because this is
using face ID it's not only just taking
a picture it's actually getting a 3D
representation of your face and it
doesn't actually send any of that data
so it's not sending Apple a picture of
your face it's basically taking the scan
and it's turning it all into ones and
zeros and data and graphs and charts and
whatever else magic that they do to make
it have a personalized audio experience
for you so let's see if we can set this
up I'm so hyped so here's our
personalized spatial Audio Oh My Gosh
okay it's happening it's happening it's
happening position your face in the
camera then move your head in a circle
to show all the angles of your face
I look up oh yeah
[Music]
but we did it
my audio has been personalized okay so
now I'm gonna put these in I'm gonna do
the ear tip fit test and we are gonna
get all fixed up Ear fit tip test
[Music]
good seal you're not gonna believe what
song just came on like absolutely not
gonna believe it the song that came on
is what does the fox say
what Does the Fox Say
oh my God what a freaking beautiful
beautiful song is the I'm one of my
favorite songs in the world and I forgot
about it I'm gonna click love
that track a friendly horse
what a great song it's kind of hard for
me to compare this to audio quality of
some of the previous ones because I
really have only been using the first
generation and it's crazy because the
sound difference is just astronomical
like I can't even there's no comparison
I'm kind of excited to go out and really
test this because I don't like loud
noises so for me being able to just wear
these out even if I'm not listening to
music I almost feel like it's going to
be life-changing like a lot of times I
will just walk around with airpods in my
ears and not be listening to anything so
I'm really excited that this is gonna
kind of I guess keep me in my own head
so as you can see the difference between
the cases this is the first gen airpods
Pro and this is airpods 2. we now have
that little additional speaker and then
over here oh look at that there is our
little lanyard Loop definitely excited
about that I do have so many airpods Pro
cases I think if you guys remember I did
a case video a long time ago and I got
so many different cases but I love that
this has the built-in lanyard super cool
the other thing that's great is you can
now charge this with an Apple Watch
charger so let me grab an Apple Watch
charger and let's test it out
[Music]
that was so
let's watch that again ready
absolutely beautiful
this is this is game changing this is
nice because the new Apple watch does
have its low power mode so you'll be
able to get additional battery life so
if I do need to stretch this a little
bit and I don't have to charge it my
Apple watch and my airpods can now take
turns
all right I'll put these back in I'm
gonna do the real test I'm gonna do the
head shake test
the real test that was smiling because
usually anytime I smile like they would
just pop right out and I'm smiling
so big and they're still in smiling and
moving my head around oh I'm dizzy what
my airpods
still in my ears so the one last thing
that we need to test here is the find my
speaker and let's see how loud this is
all right here we go
that's way louder than yeah that's I
mean you definitely be able to hear that
under close inside of your backpack
let's hear it one more time
can you see the little light blinking
let's hit the lights here we go again oh
this looks like I'm in a confessional
where I don't want to be like a voice
changed hello I'm ijustine's
um alter ego and I have a lot of secrets
to towel okay anyway
look at that it's lighting up
so it has been over a week of using the
airpods Pro 2 every single day for
workouts for editing just I don't know
existing in life and I'm so happy
because like I have said so many times
before a lot of the older airpods do not
fit in my ears except for the style of
the first gen those fit perfectly and
what I've loved so much about this
didn't even know what I was missing is
how fast the Bluetooth connectivity is
it connects so much faster than the old
versions to my phone to my iPad to my
computer and not only connecting to the
device but switching between them I
literally did not even know what I was
missing I mean it is actually night and
day of the sound quality one of the
reasons that I did really like the first
version because I could still sort of
hear my surrounding environment so when
I would be out running or walking with
airpods in I would want to be able to
hear my environment being able to use
that transparency mode has made such a
huge difference so it's basically like
I'm wearing my old air pods but I can
still listen to music and I can still
hear the world around me and I also love
how crystal clear it is like it doesn't
have a tinny sound to it it sounds like
my natural environment if I wasn't
wearing these it sounds the same it's
incredible I'm not gonna lie I haven't
actually used lanyard yet
I probably should but most of the time I
just put these in my yoga pants pocket
or I have a running belt that I use when
I run so I just put this in there I also
didn't even lose them all week which is
shocking I've enjoyed being able to
change the volume when I'm out on runs
so I don't have to use my Watch or my
phone I can just adjust it on the little
ear stem and honestly I'm so happy I
mean maybe some of you have been able to
experience these before but I have not
because they didn't have the extra small
ear tips so none of the other ones would
really have a good fit a lot of times I
would not be able to run with the old
airpods Pro like they would fall out I
have tried I've tried many times they
would stay in long enough if I'm just
sitting stationary but now with these
extra small ear tips I've been doing
runs I've done like probably maybe 20
miles over the past week and have not
had a single problem oh my God I'm so
happy you guys I just I can't even tell
you so for me this has been such a huge
upgrade from the first version now is
this a big enough upgrade for some of
you you if you already have the airpods
Pro 1 maybe not but this does have the
longer battery life you are able to get
them custom engraved with an emoji and
of course it will have two times noise
cancellation as the previous Pros yes of
course there are some pros to upgrading
to the new Pro twos but do you need to I
don't know you're gonna have to decide
on that for yourself since I have not
really used the pro version very much
but for me as an upgrade from that first
gen oh my goodness life changing
thank you guys for watching I would love
to hear more about your experience with
airpods and headphones do they fit in
your ears do they not I've also got a
bunch more Apple videos here so if you
want to check those out they're here on
the end screen so I hope you guys enjoy
those and if you haven't already please
subscribe hit the Bell to be notified
when I post new videos and I will see
you guys in the comments below and in my
next video see you later
foreign